i want to remind everybody that we have
a clip channel
i don't know why but we do uh it's
youtube.com
rotc media if you go to youtube.com rtc
media you get our clips
uh you'll enjoy them and it keeps them
separate but equal from our main channel
so youtube.com no just clips i'm talking
about
yeah okay just clips yes scripts uh
youtube.com
rotc media sign up there mike
bake it away toys guys this episode is
brought to you by johnny apple cbd it
does not turn you back people stop
stop emailing me about this what okay if
you're having that
thing if you're having issues you were
probably already
and you're just i'm sorry i haven't been
getting these emails
[Laughter]
does it turn you no these people were
already
no i didn't think they're looking for
some kind of an excuse
i didn't think it turned you they want
some kind see they don't want to just
admit that they're gay
so they're trying to come up with some
kind of gay origin story like a marvel
movie and they're trying to
the rumors they're trying to blame
johnny appleseed well i just went to
their website
what does this mean did somebody explain
what this means
i don't understand it then are people
saying that
oh [ __ ] just leave that up johnny
apple's cbd is our cbd because johnny
apple's effective affordable
and gay it won't turn your gate
mike they pay us they pay us real money
they pay us for this though
yeah if you guys want to have like this
look if you guys watch straight reads
you can go to matt christensen or tim
pool i'm sure they'll go
oh it's good dvd uh but we we [ __ ] we
move
units son uh you know who else move
units
[Laughter]
johnny apple
look uh right now we have a special uh
promotion for all you listeners
uh if you go to jacbd.com no that's not
what you think it stands for
and use promo code sorry what do you
think i think it stands for
uh jacking all cute boys
dominantly daily daily jacking
jacking all cute boys daily breed
this is the worst we should come on it's
a live read jacbd.com and a promo code
rotc support a patreon business
uh get 20 off your whole order uh thank
you to all the great people from johnny
apple cbd
supporting this program gay or straight
we love you all over there you're not
gay
i mean look i don't know maybe they are
i really don't know
i can't believe so they gave you that
new read huh yeah that's the new copy
merry christmas everybody we'll be back
revenge of this is